un concours voit les outre-mer pour
justement mettre en lumière les talents
des personnes qui peut-être n'aurais
jamais imaginé chanter au delà de leur
salle de bain ou de leur salon ou de le
re avec leurs copains et comme c'est un
concours qui est ouvert à tous
c'est trop court de voix c'est pas con
con de voix lyrique njawe cocon de voix
d'opéra
d'abord ces banques ont deux voies dans
conditionne des personnes qui chantent
de la musique religieuse de la pop du
ragga du dancehall zouk de la biguine et
tout ça et puis ensuite quand on leur
fait passer les finales régionales à ce
moment là on leur demande de travailler
un air d'opéra et c'est déjà partie de
cette sélection avec cet air d'opéra on
voit jusqu'où
l'élève peut aller et puis dans le cas
de livia louis-joseph de gain et la
présenter un extrait de la comédie
musicale à la lande
elle a suivi des cours de chant que
l'association les contre-courants lui a
payé
et puis elle s'est présentée en finale
régionale elle a gagné ensuite elle est
venue à paris elle a gagné la finale
nationale
et puis tout au long de l'année grâce à
la fondation orange elle a des cours
gratuits avec madame e cyril et madame
hartmann est avec moi même pour
justement lui présenter la présenter
dans différents concours dont celui de
pau dont celui de prodige elle a donc
aller en demi finale sk vont travailler
elle va continuer à monter
alors déjà on est ravis qu une
martiniquaise autodidacte qui vient de
martinique qui est né en martinique un
pur produit de martiniquais puisse être
allé en demi finale déjà elle part en
finale alors on croise les doigts en
président va aller jusqu'au bout avec
elle pour savoir quel sera le résultat
de la finale et je trouve aussi que
c'est une fille qui est humble c'est une
fille qui est travailleuse c'est une
fille qui se perfectionnent et sin stes
une fille qui se met toujours en
question et ont remise en question de
son travail demain soir elle est à
l'atrium dans un concert gratuit
justement offert à la fondation orange
et l'association les contre-courants à
sa vie permet à 16 ans de se verra
lettre à leurs messages et de notre
lauréate marie laure garnier d'angely de
boutdeville à l'imam andy hannah ce gars
jean-françois maras l'hiver et à celle
de ma femme c'est tout et je tanne
cambium à l'atria la tension monte ça y
est permanences pour les billets de 9h à
12h et 18h
m merci monsieur di falco alors une
question quand même un peu moins
technique
une fois que si elle gagne quel avenir
l'attend alors qu'elle gagne ou qu'elle
ne gagne pas déjà pour nous c'est une
victoire parce qu'elle est mise en
lumière
elle va rencontrer des professeurs de
chant et va pouvoir
comment dirais-je suivre une formation
toujours en martinique et pouvoir
justement à léo voir différents
professeurs de chant en métropole pour
des master classes bien sûr elle veut
devenir chat sage femme mais elle ne
vais pas abandonner sa passion et nous
croisons les doigts qu'elles puissent
suivre la voie de jessye norman barbara
hendricks ou christiane head à pierre
par le perfectionnement de sa voix parce
que c'est possible vous en est une
preuve alors on a reçu il n'y a pas très
longtemps
greg germain on va parler un petit peu
de vous quand même parce qu'on vous a
pas si souvent que ça greg germain qui a
fait partie du festival de saint pierre
que vous avez organisé et qui nous
disait ce qu'il ya d'extraordinaire avec
fabrice di falco c'est que ici en
martinique qui s'investit beaucoup mais
quand il va à l'étranger
il m'a cité les émirats rops et passe
ici je me souviens on vient le chercher
en hélicoptère c'est vrai c'est à dire
que depuis 2006 j'ai la chance de
chanter pour le sultan doman et pour les
émirs arabes et donc c'est vrai que je
reste toujours martiniquais qui essaye
dans le monde entier de faire savoir que
je suis aussi un martiniquais qui a été
comme l'hiver et joseph ii d un
autodidacte qui malheureusement a dû se
déraciner pour ali à prendre au
conservatoire mais je tiens à toujours
revenir dans mon pays pour justement
montrer que nous avons des perles
notamment martinique également dans
toutes les autres maires et aussi qu'on
peut vivre de son art nous pouvons bien
sûr vivre notre autre de notre art
nous pouvons bien sûr en vivre
normalement comme tout le monde et
surtout je crois que la plus belle
réussite c'est de pouvoir partager
échanger transmettre et être heureux de
faire chaque jour ce que non on a envie
de faire
merci beaucoup fabrique merci donc à
suivre pour pour livia pour la petite
livia